Вплив правих популістів у ЄС дедалі зростає.
Рука Кремля дотягнулася до святая святих європейської демократії -
Європарламенту, побоюються у Брюсселі.
Вони фінансують фашистські партії правого крила, прагнучи зруйнувати єдність у ЄС.
Політики з оточення Володимира Путіна вкрай зацікавлені у дестабілізації Європи.
І я боюся, що в них це вийде.
Володимир Путін надає підтримку патріотам, які поділяють його погляди. Він захищає свою країну.
Ми вирушаємо у подорож кількома європейськими містами.
Deutsche Wellе спільно з партнерським телеканалом France 24
вирішила з'ясувати, який вплив на ультраправих у Європі має Росія.
ДОВГА РУКА КРЕМЛЯ. Як Росія підтримує противників Євросоюзу
Російське посольство в Берліні.
Понад 30 років тому це приміщення відігравало важливу роль
у тоді ще соціалістичній Східній Німеччині.
А який закулісний вплив на політичне життя об’єднаної країни Кремль має сьогодні?
У Бундестазі вважають, що правопопулістська партія "Альтернатива для Німеччини"
особливо прихильна до Росії.
Йорґ Мойтен - головний кандидат від цієї партії на виборах до Європарламенту.
Ми прагнемо налагодити дружні відносини з Росією та Сполученими  Штатами Америки.
Ми виходимо виключно з практичної точки зору.
Я не представляю ані російських, ані американських інтересів.
Я - німецький політик, представник німецьких інтересів.
І в інтересах Німеччини і всієї Європи підтримувати відкриті відносини з Росією та іншими країнами.
Тим часом один представник цієї партії особливо ретельно налагоджує відносини з Росією.
Це Маркус Фронмаєр. Інші парламентарі його засуджують.
Зараз вийде російська спецслужба?
Маркус Фронмаєр за будь-якої нагоди заявляє про себе як про друга Москви.
У парі зі своєю довіреною особою Мануелем Оксенрайтером.
В інтернеті можна знайти їхні спільні фотографії.
Оксенрайтер зарекомендував себе як правий популіст,
який активно прагне встановлення ще тісніших відносин з Москвою.
Особливо у зв'язку з конфліктом між Україною та Росією.
Політик часто дає інтерв'ю російським націоналістичним ЗМІ.
Нам необхідно будувати плани на майбутнє.
І я сподіваюся, що почнемо ми з того,
що заплануємо можливий вихід з НАТО через 5-10 років.
Коли на Сході України розпочався збройний конфлікт,
Оксенрайтера бачили в оточенні проросійських сепаратистів.
Він представився спостерігачем на виборах.
Фотографи зафіксували його разом з іншими іноземцями,
в тому числі - з групою бойовиків із Франції.
Війна в Україні призвела до напруги у відносинах між Москвою та Європейським Союзом.
Усе розпочалося з анексії Криму в березні 2014 року.
Ситуація погіршилася, коли з'ясувалося, що Росія озброює сепаратистів на Сході України.
Це стало переламним моментом у геополітичній грі.
Розвиток подій у 2014 році, особливо в Україні,
посилив відносини між європейськими ультраправими і Москвою.
Після початку конфлікту між Росією та Україною, проти Росії запровадили санкції.
І у відповідь на ці заходи Кремль намагається втрутитися у голосування.
Уже тоді Володимир Путін налагоджував зв'язки з Маттео Сальвіні,
лідером італійської правопопулістської партії "Ліга Півночі", а нині - впливовим італійським міністром.
Минуло п'ять років, і тепер Сальвіні виступає за більш тісні відносини
між правопопулістськими партіями, включно з "Альтерантивою для Німеччини".
Якщо ми обєднаємо Сальвіні, Штрахе, Ле Пен та інших в одну велику групу,
вони зможуть чинити такий вплив на вибір політичного курсу,
якого не має жоден окремий політик.
Члени "Альтернативи для Німеччини" вирішили зайняти проросійську позицію.
Услід за всіма правопопулістськими партіями Європи
вони засудили введення західних санкцій проти Росії.
Витративши пять років на укладання союзу з європейськими правими радикалами,
Москва нарешті досягла успіху.
У списку головних діючих осіб виявилися кілька таємничих фігур, у тому числі Мануель Оксенрайтер.
На території Східної України у листопаді 2014 року його сфотографували
разом з колишнім солдатом - Віктором Лента та іншими добровольцями з Франції.
Всі вони - прибічники правих поглядів
і повністю заперечують ліберально-демократичні цінності.
- Ультраправі партії та організації - це одні з небагатьох політичних сил
у Європі, які все ще готові співпрацювати з Кремлем,
а Росії нині потрібні союзники на Заході.
У 2018 році рух "жовтих жилетів" організував перші акції протестів у Франції.
Навесні того ж року Віктор Лента - колишній найманець зі Східної України -
знову потрапив у поле зору журналістів. Тепер -
як член самопроголошеної служби безпеки.
- Ми - ті самі дружинники, про яких говорила префектура,
вимагаючи, щоб у всіх демонстрантів була своя внутрішня служба безпеки.
- Ви теж із "жовтих жилетів"?
- Звісно.
- Яка ваша мета? Ви до неї наблизилися?
- Послухайте, як я вже сказав, у префектурі вимагали,
щоб була служба безпеки, яка своїми силами
запобігала би будь-яким проявам насилля.
Ми хочемо показати французькому народові,
прем'єр-міністру та уряду, що ми - не джерело насилля і
що на це нас, як правило, провокують дії поліції.
Французький праворадикал Віктор Лента
перебрався з охопленої війною Східної України на вулиці Парижа.
Але в обох випадках він - найманець, який захищає інтереси Володимира Путіна.
Тим часом президент Росії відкрито налагоджує
відносини з лідерами праворадикальних партій Європи.
Приміром, із Марін Ле Пен з "Національного зібрання".
- Я знаю, що ви представляєте спектр
європейських політичних сил, що доволі швидко розвивається.
Це вкрай вигідний союз.
Щоби профінансувати свої президентські кампанії,
партія Марін Ле Пен позичила в банків, близьких до Кремля,
11 мільйонів євро. Лідерка "Національного зібрання"
продовжує підтримувати контакт із Москвою на найвищому рівні.
Приміром, через Тьєррі Маріані - колишнього міністра транспорту Франції.
Він перейшов у партію Ле Пен і визнає анексію Криму Росією.
- Я бував там понад десяток разів. Хіба можна
взагалі ставити під питання бажання мешканців Криму залишатися у складі Росії?
Нещодавно Тьєррі Маріані балотувався до Європарламенту.
Його позиція щодо Росії однозначна:
- Підтримуючи санкції, ми завдаємо такої ж шкоди
Європі та нашим фермерам, як і самій Росії. Це самогубство.
Оглядачі вважають, що Росія намагається розширити свій вплив у Європі,
надаючи підтримку лідерам правопопулістських партій
та їхнім радикально налаштованим виборцям.
- Ідея в тому, щоб постійно доливати олії у вогонь
і налаштовувати й так уже збуджених людей один проти одного.
Така собі вибухова пропаганда, скерована на те,
щоб розділити наше суспільство.
Рух "жовтих жилетів" у Франції дав можливість
популістам активізувати свою діяльність.
Майже щовихідних люди виходять на вулиці, аби взяти участь у демонстрації.
Судовий процес у цьому місті на півдні Польщі
несподівано виявив імовірні методи,
за допомогою яких Росія здійснює вплив на європейське праве крило.
Праворадикал Міхал П. перебуває під слідством через звинувачення у тероризмі.
Його обвинувачують в організації підпалу в сусідній Україні,
а саме - в Ужгороді, де проживають багато етнічних угорців.
У ніч на четверте лютого 2018 року
камера відеоспостереження зафіксувала
двох чоловіків, які намагалися кинути пляшки з запалювальною сумішшю
в будівлю угорського культурного центру.
Пошкодження будівлі виявилися незначними.
Адвокат захисту пояснює, що вимусило його клієнтів на такий вчинок.
- Був запланований умисний акт, скерований на те,
щоб розпалити в Закарпатській області
на Заході України національну ворожнечу.
Усе було влаштовано так, щоб домогтися конфлікту
між угорською меншиною з одного боку та етнічними українцями цього регіону - з іншого.
І це якраз те, про що так давно мріяли в Москві:
ще більше дестабілізувати ситуацію в Україні,
викликавши спалах міжетнічного конфлікту
на кордоні з її західним сусідом - Угорщиною.
Та ще на початку в судовому процесі у Кракові стався несподіваний поворот.
Міхал П. заявив, що до скоєння цього акту його підмовив німець Мануель Оксенрайтер.
- Він поділяє погляди Мануеля. Вони разом брали участь у кількох конференціях.
Того самого Мануеля Оксенрайтера -
правого журналіста з Німеччини, який підтримує
проросійських сепаратистів на Сході України.
У ролі свідка у Краківському суді з'явився ще один правий радикал -
Бартош Бекір. Він відмовився дати інтерв'ю знімальній групі DW.
А саме Бекір може володіти дуже важливою інформацією.
Він знає як обвинуваченого, так і Мануеля Оксенрайтера.
Бекір знайомий із ними від початку збройного конфлікту на Сході України,
коли вони разом виступили на прес-конференції
на підтримку проросійських сепаратистів.
Через місяць після першої спроби нападу в Ужгороді скоїли ще одну.
Цього разу успішно.
У скоєнні звинувачують кількох українців.
Але поки що неясно, хто за цим стоїть.
Судячи з усього, вже не ті, хто організовував перший напад.
- У Росії немає якогось єдиного центру,
де ухвалювалися б рішення щодо втручання в вибори.
Довкола Кремля зосереджені всілякі експерти,
аналітичні центри, організації та деякі впливові групи,
які хочуть отримати від Кремля ту чи іншу винагороду.
У Берліні на невеликій відстані від Бранденбурзьких воріт
стоїть радянський військовий меморіал у пам'ять
про загиблих під час Другої світової війни солдатів.
У результаті війни Німеччина та Європа були розділені,
поки не впав Берлінський мур.
Але мрії про мирне співіснування в єдиній Європі
відтоді так і не здійснилися.
Майже 30 років потому Росія, здається,
має намір знову розділити Європу.
Цього разу - за допомогою ультраправих.